كانت هذه لحظة حزينة ومُتواضعة
ذكّرتنا
بالتضحيات الهائلة التي قدمها
رجال ونساء جيش الولايات المتحدة
في
خدمة الحرية والأمن ، وأقسمت قواتنا المسلحة
اليمين لدعم
دستور الولايات المتحدة
الذي لا يخدمونه والدفاع عنه.  لتحقيق مكاسب شخصية ولكن من
أجل حماية
ورفاهية إخوانهم الأمريكيين
ووطنهم ،
فهم أبطال من أجل حرية
السلام وسيادة القانون
وبلا هوادة عندما يُطلب منهم
الدفاع عن
شعبنا وقيمنا ، فنحن مدينون لهم
ولأحبائهم بقدر
هائل
هذا هو السبب في أنني محظوظ للغاية
وامتياز للوقوف أمامكم اليوم
لتحديد المرحلة التالية من حملتنا
لهزيمة الإرهابيين الذين
ارتكبوا هجمات
على وطننا بما في ذلك أولئك الذين
يساعدونهم ويؤوونهم
ومنع أعمالهم المستقبلية.
الإرهاب
ضد أمتنا مدينون به في هذه
اللحظة للعديد من الوطنيين الذين قدموا أكبر
التضحيات ورفاقهم الذين يحملون فورًا.  rd
إرثهم
معًا حزنوا على فقدان
أكثر من
6900 جندي أمريكي ضحوا بأرواحهم
في أفغانستان والعراق ولن
ننسى أبدًا
أكثر من 52000 من الذين تحملوا
جراح الحرب
وكل من ما زالوا يحملون ندوبًا
مرئية
و  غير مرئي بحلول 15 كانون الثاني (يناير)
2021 ، سيكون حجم قواتنا في
أفغانستان
2500 جندي
سيكون حجم قوتنا في العراق أيضًا
2500 بحلول نفس التاريخ ،
وهذا يتوافق مع خططنا الموضوعة
وأهدافنا الاستراتيجية
التي يدعمها الشعب الأمريكي
ولا
يساوي  تغيير في سياستنا أو
أهدافنا علاوة على ذلك ، يستند قرار الرئيس
هذا إلى المشاركة المستمرة
مع مجلس الوزراء للأمن القومي
على مدى الأشهر العديدة الماضية